- I mean, you shoulda seen the look in Mr. Blank’s face when I ordered it, man.
I mean, it’s like he wanted to educate me right there on the spot.
♪♪♪
- We got a legend!
- [Michael Vick:] Whassup, baby?
- Michael Vick!
- [Vick:] No doubt. Thanks for havin’ me.
- Man, growin’ up—
- [Vick:] Yeah.
- You was one of my favorite players of all time. It’s you and Brett Favre, so—
- [Vick:] I mean, I’m on the list. At least I made the list.
- [Laughing]
- [Vick:] Straight up, that made me feel better.
- So, Mike, your rookie year with the Atlanta Falcons—what was your
most memorable moment you had with owner Arthur Blank?
- So, my rookie year, I wasn’t too fond of goin’ out to eat, you know—maybe like
a Ruby Tuesday’s or a Friday’s, so I’m used to
a different type of menu, you know, comin’ outta college.
Arthur, he invited me out to dinner.
You know, so I’m thinkin’, “OK, you know, it’s my first time
goin’ out to dinner with, you know, the guy who just bought the team.”
He is the big-time, you know, money man, Home Depot, and I’m like,
“I’m really not ready for this, but, you know, I’mma go.”
You know, bein’ the quarterback of the team.
So we get to the restaurant, Stoney River, out in, uh, out in Alpharetta.
I’ll never forget. We go and I’m lookin’ at this fancy menu, and
everything looked like it’s, like, Chinese language to me.
- [Laughing]
- [Vick:]  And I’m, like, “Man, look. I’m used to
seein’ a certain type of menu, not, you know, a menu
of, you know, this magnitude, where, you know, it’s the filet mignon
and porterhouse steaks. I don’t even know anything about that.”
I barely knew what the word “entree” meant.
- [Master:] How big was the menu?
- [Vick:] It was about four pages. You know, Friday’s or somethin’,
you got two pages max, you know what I’m sayin’, with the drink menu.
So, you know, I’m lookin’ at the menu, and I’m like, what do I order,
you know, without embarrassing myself or without
ordering something that might cost waaay too much?
So I’m lookin’ at the menu. I went with the most simplest thing, man.
I got chicken tenders and french fries and—
[Master laughing]
Fresh outta college, man! That’s the best I could do.
- [Master:] At a steakhouse?!
- [Vick:] Mr. Blank lookin’ at me like, “Are you serious?”
I’m like, “Yeah, because I’m not gonna foot this bill.”
- [Master:] How much were those chicken tenders and fries at a steakhouse?
- [Vick:] Probably the cheapest thing on the menu for sure.
And I don’t know if they came off the appetizer side, but
I would say no more than $20, man.
- Please tell me you had some other dipping sauce besides ketchup.
- [Vick:] I think I had the ranch dressing, man.
I went with the ranch dressing, and, I mean, you shoulda
seen the look on Mr. Blank’s face when I ordered it, man.
I mean, it’s like he wanted to educate me right there on the spot,
but, you know, I was a 21-year-old kid comin’ from where I came from
and fresh outta college, where we ate cheesesteaks and fries every day, man, so.
It wasn’t the best diet, but I was just makin’ my adjustments.
- [Master:] You said you didn’t know if Arthur Blank would pick up the check or not.
How did he end up comin’ to the conclusion that he got the check?
- That was my first time ever sittin’ down meetin’ with somebody
of that power, you know, that stature.
You know, so I was a little leery. I didn’t know—I didn’t
ask a lot of questions. Like I said, I was pretty much kinda—
I was there, you know, just hangin’ out with him.
And I’m like, “Man, I don’t know if you want me to cover the bill
or if I should pull out my credit card.”
I don’t even think I had a credit card. I think I just had cash in my pocket.
And, uh, I think I asked him at the end: “Mr. Blank, you want me to cover it?”
He was like, “Nah, man. I got you this time. But next one on you.”
- When’d you start pickin’ up that you could order
somethin’ besides chicken tenders?
- Now fast forward four years later, you know, when I’m doin’ my thing
and, you know, got a new contract.
Now I’m in the position where I can take care of the bill
and I know a little bit about eatin’ good and filet mignon
and the eight-ounce versus the 12-ounce, grass-fed.
- Lil’ cowboy ribeye, you know?
- Yeah, lil’ cowboy ribeye. You know, lil’ touch of flavor, touch of butter, garlic on it.
I think I got a bone-in ribeye. It was probably like a $85 steak, man.
And I, so I took advantage of the opportunity when it came around.
- You smartened up.
- [Vick:] Yeah.
- You knew the best cut to get.
- [Vick:] And I probably had about $1,000 in my pocket
just in case I had to cover the bill.
- [Laughing]
- But I learned how to do it different, so that was really,
really cool—him watchin’ me
grow up, you know, from chicken tenders to the filet mignon.
- We callin' pockets too?
- [Vick:] My overall record when we was young probably was, like,
310 and, like, 30.
I was the man in my day.
- 310 and 30?
- [Vick:] Yeah.
So now I'm about to be 311 and 30.
- [Master:] That's what you think.
- Keep it goin'.
- We gon' see what's up.
All right, you talkin' all that noise right now.
Thanks for kickin' it with us.
Subscribe to B/R to check out more dope videos like this one.